So Turkey has now struck Kurdish targets in
Northeastern Syria according to a new report.
Now when we say, as I just discussed with
you, uh, we all want to be out of Syria, but
if we just bail Turkey will attack the Kurds.
It's not a hypothetical political consideration.
It's not some random way to try to criticize
what Donald Trump does. It's real. And in
fact, it happened within hours of the United
States pulling troops from Northern Syria
in conjunction with Donald Trump's announcement.
Right after, even some Republicans said, wait,
wait, wait a second. What about the Kurds?
Turkey has already struck targets belonging
to Kurdish opposition groups in the Northeast
of Syria. Right now, the North of Syria is
controlled by the Kurdish SDF. That's Syrian
democratic forces. They are our allies. They've
been fighting ISIS. This is why, this is what
better said. A lot of Trumpists don't get
who just continue to see all of this as team
sports.
The actions of Trump have real world consequences
and you have these sort of reflexive defenses
of anything that Donald Trump does no matter
what it is. But then you see that the impact
is real. Trump pulls troops, Turkey bombs,
the Kurds. Now, Trump said, we have the tweet
that he would obliterate Turkey's if they
do the wrong thing to the Kurds. We looked
at the tweet last segment. Let's look at it
one more time. As I have strongly stated before
Trump tweeted yesterday, and just to reiterate,
if Turkey does anything that I, in my great
and unmatched wisdom considered to be off
limits, I will totally destroy and obliterate
the capital E economy of Turkey I've done
before. We still don't know what that I've
done before means none of this is surprising.
We've known for a long time that Turkey and
air Dhawan wanted to attack the Kurds.
Now, there is a very obvious and cynical analysis
to be made. I will present it to you. There
are Trump towers in Turkey. Urdu one knows
something about the Khashoggi killing that
would be bad for Trump to have go public.
Given that Trump did nothing with regards
to Saudi Arabia after we found out about Saudi
Arabia's role, responsibility in that killing
both Putin and Erdogan want serious regime
to stand. So this becomes a really clever
geopolitical proxy to repress the Kurds, a
more egalitarian society in supportive dictator
Bashar Al Assad. And Trump is the perfect
Patsy to fold under the most minor pressure.
This, that's one analysis. Okay. And that
accounts for like 95% of what we know and
what we're seeing. It would explain 95% of
the factors. Now let me address another issue.
There are some leftists who are saying Trump
derangement syndrome is making leftists defend
troops in Syria.
Trump has so rattled the left that he is making
the left be in favor of forever Wars just
to oppose Donald Trump. Um, when did the left
become warmongers is another way that it's
being said. Stop back up a second. Okay. This
is a very specific situation that we are analyzing
here. Noam Chomsky, no hero of American imperialism
and military expansion has said it makes sense
for the U S to maintain a presence in Syria
right now to deter attacks against the Kurds.
To pretend that recognizing the folly of this
decision by Donald Trump is a militaristic
decision of expanding forever. Wars is extraordinarily
myopic and it's also dangerous to the Kurds
to start pushing lines like that. Geopolitics
is complicated, much more complicated than
troops anywhere are bad. Get them all out
anytime, no matter what. No matter why, uh,
please apply a little more thought to what
is going on here because it is, I mean, listen,
we expect the right to be making completely
ridiculous fact free analysis of what we are
seeing take place on the foreign policy stage.
Whether they reflectively reflexively defend
any decision that Trump makes, whether they
reflexively favor and support anything that
involves putting the military in different
places, we expect this from them. The the
really disgusting thing that I don't want
to see is the left starts to starting to eat
itself over analyses that make no sense. This
is not about opposing Trump and therefore
supporting forever Wars or endless indefinite
military engagements. It's just not. This
is about understanding what even people like
Noam Chomsky are saying and recognizing that
they're with Trump as always. Maybe other
factors, financial factors, leverage factors,
et cetera that are not being publicized. That
could very much inform why we're seeing what
we're seeing. We'll be tracking the fallout.
Make sure that you're following the daily
[inaudible]
packing show on Instagram at David Pakman
show. And while you're there, follow me at
David dot pack